the symbol i want to talk about is the
symbol for pattern speed which is the
greek capital omega with a little
subscript p after it most of my research
is spent uh studying galaxies and which
is a glorious thing to do because
galaxies are some of those beautiful
things there are out there and if you
actually look at a picture of a galaxy
here's a nice picture of a galaxy this
is a very famous galaxy the whirlpool
galaxy m51
and if you look at pictures of galaxies
what makes them beautiful is this
beautiful spiral structure that you
often see in them it's different kinds
of galaxies but the spiral galaxies tend
to have this very elegant spiral
structure and it's kind of a
little bit of a paradox in astronomy
as to how these spiral arms are actually
there
because if you actually measure how fast
things are going around a galaxy you
find that the things at the outside are
basically going around the galaxy at the
same thing speed as things very close to
the center of the galaxy i mean if you
do a little ford experiment of instead
of having a spiral galaxy like this if
you actually were to say set up a a
group of runners on a running track and
arrange them in a beautiful spiral
pattern on the running track um and then
make them run a race but all stay in
their lanes and they're all sort of
equivalent runners so they all run at
the same speed what you'd find is very
quickly the poor guys in the outside
lanes will get very left behind because
they've got a lot further to go that
means that your beautiful spiral pattern
wouldn't last right because the guys on
the outside would get left behind the
ones in the middle would quickly run
away and so the pattern itself would
very quickly get wound up into a very
tight pattern
and there's a thing called the winding
paradox that basically says that because
stars in a galaxy all go around more or
less at the same speed you can't
maintain a beautiful structure like this
for very long because it would very
quickly the stars on the outside were
left behind and the ones in the middle
would run away and so you wouldn't end
up with this beautiful spiral structure
but we do but we do and so people
started worrying about this in the 1960s
and realized that there was a possible
solution which is that maybe the thing
you're looking at isn't a sort of a
fixed spiral pattern but it's actually a
wave
just like a sound wave in the air for
example it's a wave of density that's
traveling around the galaxy
and the nice thing about waves
is that they don't have to travel at the
same speed as the medium that they're in
so for example sound in air travels at
300 meters per second and it doesn't
matter if the wind's blowing at five
meters per second or 10 meters per
second you can still have a sound wave
propagating through it and so the idea
is it's the same thing going on here you
have kind of a wave of density that's
traveling through this thing and what
you're actually seeing in the beautiful
sort of lit up spiral arms is where that
there's that maximum of density and
where you have that maximum density you
end up making stars and you're basically
seeing the young stars forming in those
spiral arms but then the what the
pattern will travel around uh sort of
independent of the speed which
individual stars are traveling within
the galaxy
what's made this wave and what's what is
the wave so
those are two quite difficult questions
neither of which really has a definitive
answer yet what makes the wave is not
entirely clear in the case of
the whirlpool galaxy this guy here
what this picture doesn't show is that
just off the edge of the picture there
is this galaxy has a companion and so
it's thought in that case the companion
is sort of stirring up this wave as it's
traveling around the whirlpool galaxy
in other cases it's really less clear
and one of the things that i've been
trying to do by studying this thing the
pattern speed which is basically just
how fast that pattern's rotating how
fast the waves traveling around the
galaxy is trying to answer some of those
questions trying to figure out exactly
what the nature of the wave is whether
it really is going to last for a long
time
and and you know what its ultimate
fight's gonna be whether this spiral
structure would eventually just
disappear
if it wasn't for these waves
what would the galaxy look like they'd
be very boring they really would because
it's these these beautiful waves
traveling around are the thing that sort
of makes the thing that makes the galaxy
look pretty and it's really it's again
rather analogous to the ocean right the
oceans when they're flat are really
pretty dull things to look at it's the
waves traveling in and breaking on the
shore the things that makes the ocean
look pretty and it's kind of the same
thing here that there are waves
traveling around this thing and they're
sort of lighting up the galaxy as they
go and they're really what makes the
galaxy look so beautiful there's lots of
speculation and there's lots of
different questions that you can try and
answer by measuring these pattern speeds
in these galaxies for example another
kind of galaxy um has these bar
structures in the middle and again it's
thought to be more or less the same
thing that there's a pattern there
that's rotating
and
a few years ago there was a theory that
said that these bars shouldn't actually
be rotating very quickly because the
interaction between that bar and the
dark matter that fills the galaxy should
make the bar slow down essentially the
bar should just
sort of by a friction type process
should lose its rotational motion and
slow down
so we made some of the first ever
measurements of pattern speeds and
actually found that most of these bars
weren't slowing down at all they were
whizzing around at high speed and that
then led to people changing their ideas
a little bit about the nature and
distribution of dark matter within
galaxies so as well as sort of telling
you something about the galaxy itself
you can use these measurements of
pattern speeds within galaxies to try
and learn other things about the
properties of the galaxy itself in
simple terms you're basically measuring
how many degrees per second the galaxy
goes around now because it takes
hundreds of millions of years for a
galaxy to rotate the number of degrees
per second that it rotates at is a tiny
number so it's not usually the unit that
you actually use but that really is the
fundamental unit is radians or the unit
of angle per second or degrees per
second is really what you're measuring
the measurements are sufficiently
difficult that there's probably half a
dozen galaxies in total these
measurements have been made for and
indeed some go faster than others and
one of the things we're just starting to
try and do is try and figure out what
the difference is why is it that some
are going faster than others there's one
further subtlety here which is that
we've developed the technique to a point
where we can actually not only measure a
pattern speed for a whole galaxy but see
whether the pattern speed actually
varies with position in the galaxy in
other words it sort of goes back to this
winding paradox are these things really
sort of set structures that just sit
there for hundreds of millions of years
or is the pattern actually evolving are
different bits of the pattern going
around at different speeds and again the
slightly surprising result we found from
that is that the answer is it depends
which galaxy you look at some of them do
seem to have these nice sort of set
patterns that are set for all time other
galaxies seem to be evolving very
quickly
our sun as i understand it currently
sits in one of the milky way's arms
does that mean the time will come when
we're no longer in an hour yeah we
travel in and out of the arms over time
and in fact the arm we're in at the
moment is not the arm we were in when
the sun was formed so the sun sort of
might is migrating its way around the
milky way and spend some of its time in
spiral arms some of its time not in
spiral arms does the sun move into and
out of the arms or do the arms sweep
through the sun it depends where you are
in the galaxy okay in some parts of the
galaxy the stars are actually traveling
faster than the pattern in other parts
of the galaxy the pattern's travelling
faster than the stars so in some places
the wave kind of catches up with the
stars in other places the stars catch up
with the waves one of the pieces of
evidence that um
that these things really are waves that
are causing star formation comes from
studying supernova studying exploding
stars
um and so in this this galaxy the
whirlpool galaxy turns out there have
been several supernovae in recent times
um so in 2000 so here's a picture of the
galaxy in 2000 something five you can
see this bright object appeared here
that someone's conveniently put little
yellow marks in to guide the eye but
there was a supernova and then in summer
2011 another of these supernovae went
off now the thing about the supernovae
is they tend to be very massive stars
they're the only ones that really
explode in this particular type of
supernova um and the thing about very
massive stars is they have very short
lifetimes at least in terms of you know
a galaxy's lifetime and the rotation of
the galaxy and so on which means that
they basically explode at the same place
the star was born
and the interesting point to note here
is that both of these supernovae occur
within the spiral arms so this is
telling you where star formation is
actually going on and the star formation
really is going on within the spiral
arms and it's an indication that the
spiral arms are the the site of star
formation because that's where the gas
is being compressed by this density wave
that then leads to star formation that
then very rapidly leads to the most
massive stars exploding a supernova